we begin with breaking news overnight
regarding what was hurricane lane late
last night the storm weakened a bit and
is now a tropical storm but is still a
danger to the Hawaiian Islands Lane has
maximum sustained winds of about 65
miles an hour it has brought torrential
rains and severe flooding forcing people
to flee to safety the rain and damaging
winds are expected to continue today the
storm is about 135 miles south of
Honolulu heading north-northwest toward
the island chain it's projected to veer
west skirting the islands at about 3
miles per hour but is not expected to
make landfall
Matea the area is in Lahaina on the
island of Maui the day of the morning
well good morning you know what we're
seeing right now here Maui is of rain
throughout the night here in Maui and on
the Big Island here's part of the
problem this storm is moving extremely
slow it is going 2 to 5 miles per hour
so it is lingering and it is dumping
rain it's hard to believe but if it
thinks keep up at this pace lane could
actually break the all-time record on
the Big Island for the most rain coming
from a tropical system in the u.s. that
was just set by hurricane Harvey last
year as late weekend Friday officials
said it had already taken a catastrophic
toll on Hawaii's Big Island there have
been no reports of any deaths or
injuries we dodged a bullet doesn't mean
it's over we're going to have rain and
wind and local flooding and we need to
be vigilant the storm inundated the
island overflowing rivers triggering
landslides flooding streets and turning
stairwells into waterfalls
lamed of more than three feet of rain in
some areas the ground is so soaked in
some places that it can no longer absorb
any of the downpour it just sucked never
have I seen it like this
in 43 years Lane has been downgraded to
a tropical storm but not before
spreading wind and rain on Hawaii's more
populated islands of Oahu and Maui in
Waikiki tourists were warned to stay out
of the water as lane creep closer
kick it up dangerously high surf friday
gusty winds on Maui push a fast-growing
wildfire that forced some residents to
evacuate their homes both islands are
expecting more rain today
and some business owners prepared for
the worst laying down sandbags and
enough Windows Feliz stockpiled relief
supplies in Honolulu prepping for a
storm that forecasters feared put a bit
Hawaii's worst in a generation for now
some residents say they're ready for a
return to normal when will you breathe
the sigh of relief I think we're
starting to already a little bit Lane is
being blamed for leaving about 5,000
residents without power after gusty
winds damaged electrical equipment and
it could be a few days before they get
their power back but we are hearing a
bit of good news from Oahu it turns out
that their beaches should be open later
today Michelle good news for a state
that just seems to can't cut a break
Mireya Villarreal in Lahaina Maui thank
you